>> Neil: ALL RIGHT, CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW, THAT IS
THE GOVERNOR THERE, GAVIN NEWSOM
ON HOW HE WILL SLOWLY REOPEN
CHURCHES AND PLACES OF WORSHIP
THROUGHOUT THE GOLDEN STATE.
IT COULD BE PROBLEMATIC.
TRACE GALLAGHER HAS MORE FROM
LOS ANGELES.
PPE EVEN THOUGH THE NINTH
COURT OF APPEALS HAS BLOCKED,
DOMINIC ADAM NEWSOM HAS DECIDED
TO OPEN THEM ANYWAY AND IS
ALLOWING THE COUNTIES TO OPEN
THEM IMMEDIATELY IF THEY CHOOSE.
PLACES OF WORSHIP CAN STAY CLOSE
THAT THEY WANT TO.
IF THEY DO DECIDE TO OPEN, THE
GOVERNOR HAS LAID OUT NEW
GUIDELINES, AND THEY ARE
EXTENSIVE.
THEY MUST LIMIT CAPACITY TO 25%
OR 100 PEOPLE DEPENDING ON THE
SIZE OF THE BUILDING.
ALL EMPLOYEES AND VOLUNTEERS
WILL BE TRAINED ON HOW TO KEEP
THE VIRUS FROM SPREADING.
ANYONE ATTENDING OUR PRESIDING
OVER A RELIGIOUS SERVICE WOULD
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK.
THE STATE HAS RECOMMENDED
ELIMINATING ALL SINGING
ESPECIALLY BY A CHOIR.
A SOCIAL DISTANCING WOULD STILL
BE REQUIRED.
CATHOLICS WOULD NEED TO RE-WORD
THINGS LIKE COMMUNION AND
CONFESSION AND AT SOME MOSQUES
ABOUT BANNING THAT SHARING OF
PRAYER RUGS.
WE SHOULD NOTE THAT THERE IS NO
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM.
THE SHERIFF IS NOT GOING TO COME
TO THE CHURCHES THAT HARASS
PEOPLE.
NO ONE IS GOING TO KNOCK ON THE
CONFESSIONAL.
IT’S ALL ABOUT SELF POLICING.
ALL OF THIS COMES AS TO CHURCHES
IN CALIFORNIA HELD SERVICES
WITHOUT PERMISSION, BOTH
SERVICES TURNED OUT TO BE THE